Fire Department doesn't want to show up Jason Momoa did his best to make the best of a nightmare situation the actor got stuck in an elevator at his hotel in Vancouver Canada on Monday with his dog and a group of friends really Jason documented the experience on his in story so we could all experience the cobia joked about who they were going to eat first me Amana we we live and they noted that all they had to nibble on was a bag of peanut M&Ms at one point they even had a mini dance party Oh Jason stunt team showed up to help there's my team but they ended up doing a little damage in their attempt to escape turn you out man you know the time to be like diehard but didn't work out and while Jason didn't document the moment he got out it appears they made it out eh okay Jason shared this video to his story laying in bed with his puppies but again well [Music]